they can't actually protect the few
brands that are still willing to remain
on the platform the Media Matters uh CEO
Angelo kuson uh if I I think I'm getting
his name right or maybe kosone uh he the
same guy who did not want me there he is
there he is uh this is uh him on MSNBC
yesterday continuing to go after Elon
and Twitter that the platform is so
saturated with extremism with white
genocide with anti-Semitism with racis M
with conspiracy theories things that
otherwise should be managed in some way
that they can't actually protect the few
brands that are still willing to remain
on the platform and this has actually
been an ongoing thing for the last few
months this is just the latest and
actually a string of these instances so
I think the most important thing though
is that he confirmed that we were right
oh so Media Matters in Angelo they're
very very concerned about all the hate
on Twitter now it's funny because before
Elon got Twitter they weren't worried
about that right they
there was plenty of hate on Twitter I
used to get a ton of hate from the left
when say I left the left and I would
have progressives telling me to kill
myself and that they were going to come
kill me and a whole bunch more they
didn't really care about that but they
are making it clear that Elon Musk is
Enemy Number One and again why is he
Enemy Number One well it linked back to
everything we covered earlier it links
back to that conversation with Joe Rogan
that Twitter before Elon was basically a
an apparatus of the government to s
anyone who did not fall in line with
leftist
Orthodoxy